cbs news political analyst reince
priebus who was president trump's former
chief of staff
joins us with a former senior adviser to
president
barack obama that's valerie jarrett good
morning to you both
all right guys here we are the day is
finally here it was a late night for
both the candidates
this is a question for both of you which
states are you watching for
and is there one state in particular
that you'll say
we got this valerie can you start us off
please
well sure florida i think is going to be
essential if
vice president biden wins florida then i
think it's going to be really tough for
president trump to bring it home
but i think there are lots of states in
play gail i think
look the fact that president obama went
to georgia that texas is in play it
shows
vice president biden has really
broadened the map and reached out
broadly across america
and i think today is a day that all of
you who haven't voted have an
opportunity to go out there and make
sure your voices are heard
and then we have to give time to count
the ballots and i think that's important
that we have an open and fair election
which means counting it all the way to
the end
yeah they don't call them battleground
states for nothing right your turn
you bet well i agree with valerie on
florida and the great thing as you
reported earlier florida is going to
count them up pretty quickly we're going
to know florida we're going to know a
lot about the country when you look at
certain counties in florida and
who lives in those counties and how the
candidates did so florida number one
coming out of the gate for president
trump very important number two up right
on the east coast uh
and in eastern time zone two early uh
vote count type state is north carolina
i think north carolina is going to tell
us a lot
i think if trump puts north carolina in
his bucket and then goes to ohio which
is going to be another state's going to
count them up
pretty quickly ohio so if trump hits
florida north carolina ohio
my guess is is that he's going to also
do enough
in georgia and arizona to hold and then
what you're looking at for donald trump
is he needs to win one
of the three midwest states the big ones
wisconsin michigan or pennsylvania
i do think it's coming down to
pennsylvania there's a reason why both
candidates are camped out there
right the president continues to stoke
uncertainty about this election raising
skepticism
about the counting of ballots
threatening to send in lawyers right
away
why is he taking this approach
well i think you're going to find out i
think the president's verbal about it
but i think both candidates are
are already by the way both campaigns
have lawyers right now
in pennsylvania they've been there for
days they're reviewing
enormous amount of absentee ballots
they're reviewing the postmarks they're
reviewing signatures
there are lawyers from both campaigns
the dnc the rnc
if this comes down to mail-in ballots
they are going to review them it's what
every campaign does for 20 years
before i was chairman of the rnc i was
general counsel of the rnc i headed up
election day operations which was mostly
lawyers
that's what campaigns do tony
valerie if president trump attempts to
declare victory
early as has been rumored he might do
what
what would the biden campaign's response
be
well look first of all i don't think he
should we ought to be able to
wait until every vote is counted the
american people are showing up at the
polls and why would
president trump want to preempt their
opportunity to weigh
in and make sure that their vote does
count and so
i think the biden campaign as lawyers as
well
just as rand said ready to go into court
if necessary to protect
the right of every american's vote to
count
reince let's take a look at the early
turnout so far over 90 million people
have already cast their votes early
the thinking among some of the pollsters
is that this that favors joe biden
president trump says not so fast there's
a red wave coming because my people will
vote on election day
do you think that that will be enough to
make up the margin and you believe that
early turnout favors biden over
president trump
well first of all your premise to the
question all the lead up
it's 100 true um there's three buckets
of voting that that we
talk about in politics one is absentee
ballot voting
which we know what that is the other is
early vote that's when you go to a poll
before the election date in person
so that's the second bucket the third
bucket is election day voting
in bucket one and two the democrats have
historically done better than
republicans they liked voting early
and they did so again this time in in
records amounts although a lot of
republicans came out
and voted early which closed the gap
between the two parties
president trump is going to do better on
election day in almost every
battleground state in america it's just
i don't think valerie would even
disagree with that so the question is
going to be
um what does what do those three buckets
look like at the end of the day
i think the trump campaign thinks
they've got enough out there
today to to put into the third bucket to
win the election
all right reince and valerie thank you
so much looking forward to spending the
night with both of you tonight
bring your pajamas in a
you gail pillow very excited about
tonight thank you both
cbs news will bring you election results
in a prime time special tonight cbs news
20 20.
election night america decides nora
o'donnell is leading our coverage
i'll be joining her along with margaret
brennan john dickerson and ed o'keefe
starts valerie and reince as you know
will be here too it starts at 6 30
eastern right here on
cbs it starts at 6 30. no end time yeah